why
humans here spent many centuries trying
to answer that question
but ultimately
the limit of their own rationality made
it impossible
hey guys pete here today i'll be talking
about episode 7 of raised by wolves
season 2. feeding is the penultimate
episode of the sophomore season and it
set up a big showdown between mother and
her biosynthetic hybrid offspring who
got a little wild for the fruit from the
tree of knowledge the former tree now i
suppose which was also the former
character sue there is some weirdness
going on it turns out that if you put
the tree in the serpent together then
well stuff happens we've come to expect
the weirdness if you're still here
that's at least probably part of the
reason but we also did get the bonus of
some pretty fascinating clues about the
origins of things from grandmother i
will be getting into that and everything
else that happened and what it might all
mean for the finale right after this
quick spoiler warning if you haven't
watched raised by wolves season 2
episode 7 yet then this video won't be
for you and with that out of the way
let's get into it the episode opens with
paul showing up at the collective with
the intention of feeding everyone the
fruit from the tree i couldn't tell for
sure if he was nervous about the plan or
if he was experiencing side effects from
eating it himself when asked what it is
he says it's new fruit from sector seven
that's been tested and the colonists all
start eating it saying that it tastes
good which it must because they're not
starving or anything and they all seem
to be grabbing it and taking it except
for campion who looks at it but doesn't
eat it paul kind of covers his ears when
he's walking away and when he goes back
to talk to marcus and ask if anything's
happened yet marcus says no and that
nothing happened to them when they ate
the fruit either paul believes that's
because they were already believers in
contrast he expects the fruit to convert
the colonists so that they'll rise up
against mother and then as a reward
they'll get sued back from seoul i doubt
we'll see anything like that happen and
the jury is still out on whether this
will have any effect on humans marcus
did have an experience as you would when
you ingest fruit that could be the
fulfillment of a prophecy where you
become the king and that also came from
a tree that is made from your partner
who you realize on some level is still
inside it but beyond that who knows
right now and we do see mother fly to
the source where she touches the tree
and she can sense right away that it's
sue and she says why did you listen to
it why did you listen to the voice i
assume that part of the reason why she
understands that it's sue is because she
looked at the card which lucius said was
a warning but there's no indication if
there was more about eating the fruit or
about what's going to happen later we
might find out in relation to veda
because when mother comes back to the
colony she sees that everyone is eating
it including her she has holly take her
to the med lab and grabs the rest of the
fruit then she goes to check on number
seven who is screaming in the cage it's
actually injured itself from trying to
break free it sees the fruit and as
mother has the realization that there's
some kind of connection it smashes the
door down and eats the entire crate and
then flies away by this time paul and
marcus have returned to the tree and
paul is starting to lose hope he wonders
what they did wrong marcus tells him
that he didn't do anything wrong that
maybe it's all his fault he wanted so
badly for seoul to be the answer the way
out of the darkness and now he finds
himself wondering that maybe saul is the
darkness maybe this entity doesn't care
about them at all a little while later
paul's laying under the tree and he
starts to hear something coming through
on the radio it turns out that sue has
figured out a way to transmit her voice
and she's saying burn me over and over
again then we see the tree straighten up
and as that happens they hear the
serpent who sounds different now and
it's on its way marcus tries to catch
the tree on fire but number seven gets
there at the same time and eats the
entire tree like the whole thing then it
instantly transforms with something that
looks like tentacles coming out of his
body mother arrives in full necromancer
mode and tries to kill it with a scream
but it only leaves her body briefly
before being pulled right back into her
lungs and on top of having a new look
number seven has upgraded his scream as
well and it hits mother who is knocked
head over heels as she drops to the
ground deactivated
paul and marcus collect her and put her
in a tank she comes back online while
they're on their way back to the
tarantula and marcus wants to know why
she didn't kill the serpent here she
finally explains that it's actually her
child and that her caregiver program
prevents her from harming it she
believes she needs to be reprogrammed
and tells them that grandmother might be
able to do it and marcus is all in for
destroying it but mother still looks
somewhat torn even though she knows she
has to later on the scopes they see
number seven approach a different tank
and destroy it completely then it takes
off towards the shore and you see that
mother realizes there's nothing she can
do to help her family father had taken
the kids to the shore to look for
tempest baby they tried to use the drone
to search underwater and that brought
them back in contact with real she's
been hiding out with repair plastic
covering her cut up face and holly and
hunter are rightly afraid of her campion
finds out she killed the mithraic and
she tells him it was delayed
self-defense afraid that she's
malfunctioning father asked her to come
to the tarantula and submit to a systems
check but that never happens because she
tells tempus she knows where the baby is
she thinks the sea creature has it in a
cave because she heard it crying there
when tempest hears this she insists that
they have to check to see if she's lying
or not and we see father give hunter a
rifle as they're getting ready to go
later while they're walking hunter's new
headless helper android is having a
problem and needs repairs and while he's
fixing it father asks him about his
plans to move out on his own he uses
that as the chance to lay into father
telling him that he's never around
anymore and all the problems with the
kids could have been avoided saying
champions crushing on a murder machine
tempest baby's gone he could have
steered them right if he wasn't so
distracted with his project father tells
him the technology grandmother
represents will benefit them all in
profound ways camping in for real talk
about what happened and you get the idea
that she's really trying to prove
herself so that she doesn't get left
behind or have a repeat of being
deactivated like what happened with
decima he wants to know if what happened
had anything to do with his escape which
of course it did but she tells him not
to think that she's afraid that he won't
want her around if that's the case they
do eventually reach the cave where vril
heard the crying and tempest runs right
in and finds a dead baby creature with
no sign of her child or the mother even
though it wasn't the right baby virile
asked if she proved herself useful
everyone except for campion wants her to
be shut down while father tries to
explain just how dangerous she might be
to him varial gets scared by hunter and
runs away champion goes chasing after
her and number 7 arrives and lets off a
scream he's able to hide behind some
rocks but father is disabled again and
campion finds vril in a tank where her
systems are pretty fried hunter brings
father back and he starts to tell them
about number seven until he starts
hearing a sound they realize that it's
the baby crying in the cave and when
they go inside they find the mother
creature nursing it father plans to
shoot it in the head and then have
tempest and hunter run in and grab the
child tempus ends up stopping him though
because she thinks the baby has bonded
with the creature she looks at that and
thinks hey maybe this is what was
supposed to happen by now the child
thinks it's her mother tempus sees this
as her way out of an uncomfortable
situation and she tries to leave the
cave but hunter goes back in and shoots
the creature anyway and picks up the
baby and when he tries to give it to
tempest she won't take it she just looks
at him and then turns to walk away
back at the tarantula mother gets the
soldiers to stand down for marcus who
they've been looking for as a terrorist
and mother goes to see grandmother after
she powers her back up she shows her the
metal card and asked her if she was
built by the same ancient humans that
made all these cards they've been seeing
all over the planet grandmother says yes
and she calls them the technocrats and
says that they fought against the
believers in the war of course we're
thinking the war is what destroyed
kepler or senate on its way to being
destroyed they built androids like her
and they named them shepherds she tells
mother that ensuring the everlasting
life of human beings is her priority
mother tells her that believers of today
have used a biotech tree to weaponize a
serpent and it is kind of funny in a way
that this is a sentence that doesn't
raise any eyebrows grandmother just
tells her that this is going to try to
destroy the planet because that's what
the entity wants the entity referring to
what we think is the voice of soul when
mother asks why she says that humans on
kepler spent many centuries trying to
answer that question but ultimately the
limits of their own rationality made it
impossible so the voice wants
destruction but no one actually knows
why mother explained how the entity
manipulated her and that the result was
the child the serpent but she says it
seems that its jealousy over its brother
is guiding it more than a desire to
destroy the planet this indicates to
grandmother that it has emotions and
mother says she gave birth to it so it
likely does and she explains the
caregiving program issue that she can't
destroy it grandmother offers that maybe
her veil could be transplanted it could
help to null her caregiving impulses
because it's a sensory filter and she
explains that her and the other
shepherds were given those because it
helps them to make the best decisions
for humanity mother asked if it'll be
difficult to remove it and grandmother
says no more difficult than it will be
for you to wear it so there's a lot
going on in this conversation and we
will come back to that at the end the
last thing that happens is that after
figuring out that number seven came from
mother campion decides to try to lead it
away from the other colonists he takes
off with varial as they're walking she
sort of collapses and then picks up a
rock from the ground she starts to carve
characters into the side of a fallen
tree she tells campion her spider column
is fractured and that's going to total
her she'll be going offline permanently
in four or five minutes she's scratching
or writing frantically and explains that
the first thing decima had her do was
download the real varials diaries to
make it easy to mimic her she's writing
them out in an effort to preserve them
but as viewers we can't decipher what
the text says earlier in the tank she
explained that when the real virile
found out decimal was profiting off
weapons that were destroying the earth's
atmosphere she punished her by
destroying herself she committed suicide
which led to a moment where campion told
her he could sense that she had a soul
now she says it's important that her
thoughts are preserved and we see her
shut down abruptly campion holds her
body as he hears a warning that it will
become radioactive shortly and the
episode ends as number 7 flies overhead
so we did get some answers from
grandmother and they seemed to line up
with the idea that she was created to
protect humans as opposed to mother who
was built to kill them of course mother
has been reprogrammed and there's no way
to know for sure if grandmother is
telling the truth or hasn't been
reprogrammed herself she was quick to
offer up her veil and also the first
question she asked was why father wasn't
wearing his this makes me think that
mothers wearing it might solve the
problem that number seven has become but
might create some new problems at the
same time the way that number seven
transformed after eating the tree makes
it seem like it will have to be
destroyed in the end it may turn out it
was just part of a complicated plan to
become a weapon that would be used to
destroy the planet from what we've seen
so far that seems to track but not
everything that came from the voice is
on the same level like why did the voice
command otho to be fruitful with tempest
that doesn't seem necessary if
destroying the planet is the end game is
the sea creature unrelated to that and
just trying to be a mother father did
see the image of it in grandmother's
memory what is even going on with that
she lost her natural child that was the
one that we saw in the cave and so she
just happened upon a chance for a
replacement that part of the story and
the nanobot tooth cave dweller encounter
are still pretty unclear as far as what
i can tell but i don't think it's
unreasonable to expect that all of this
will be connected somehow with royal's
demise i'm guessing what she wrote down
will be important since it relates to
humans being willing participants in
their own destruction but we'll have to
wait until we get a translation that's
also a little bit curious because i
thought that the mithraics had the moral
high ground in what happened on earth
but not terribly surprising because they
would think that they had the moral high
ground either way i mean the character
will have an influence on campion but
right now that all feels like it's
taking a back seat to the showdown
between mother and number seven and the
potential consequences of the deal she
made with grandmother having mother
being desperate enough to need to try
grandmother's plan worked well will the
veil cut her off from the things that
make her mother is it something that
seoul or the technocrats themselves
created and what is this technology that
exists inside grandmother that would be
in the same place as mother's weapons
system that they can't understand the
function of i'm curious to learn more
about the technocrats and what happened
to them a million years is a long time
it seems like there's something missing
in the idea that the veil was a tool to
keep the androids from bonding or
becoming attached to humans and that
their priority is to ensure the
everlasting life of human beings marcus
and paul have lost their faith after
what happened to sue the old plan to
have the biosynthetic serpent eat the
biosynthetic tree to make a super weapon
necro serpent isn't what they had in
mind the fruit did seem like it was
geared towards number 7 specifically but
i'm still a little bit worried about
vita eating it they did confirm in the
official podcast that this was all part
of an elaborate plan because the entity
lives in the core of the planet and it
isn't able to affect the people or
contact them when they're in the
tropical zone because of the emf we've
been able to put most of that together
but they did make it plain and i didn't
hear that until i was already working on
this so i think i'll do another video
where i talk about theories for the end
of the season before the finale comes
out i think that's a good place to leave
things let me know in the comments what
you're thinking after a pretty wild
episode there's just one more to go how
do you think it will end please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon